あ～
お～
あぁ～
あれ？  あれ？
なんか耳が麻痺ってんだけど
あぁ～
お～
あ！あ！あ！
おー！
耳かきってこうちょっと
くいってなってるからさちょっと
痛いじゃないですか
あのガリってされてる感じ
それに対して綿棒は
こう、ふんわりしてるから
こう、なんか…
あぁっ
気持ちいいよね
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
耳かきか、綿棒かで言ったら
どっちかと言うと綿棒を使っていますが
今回はこの耳かき界に
新たな風が吹きららららら～らら
ババーン
綿棒にサヨナラ
Ea・Vacuum・Cleaner(耳吸引クリーナー)
こんなのが今あるみたいですよ
耳の中にこれを、ぶっさすんだってさ
耳の中を傷つけよう。(？)
あっ
綿棒を入れると耳の中が傷つくから
これのもう吸い取ってやろうって言う考え
これからこのバキュームで吸い取って
耳の中の耳垢を全部吸い取るらしいです
みんな笑顔で使ってますね
おめでとうございます（？）
僕も綿棒を使ってると
たまに耳に刺さっちゃうんで
ちょっと痛いんで
今回これをちょっと実際に使ってみましょう
バキッコンひょい
こんなかんじですな
電池、単三2本いります
これで これで
これで
これを耳にぶっさして
耳の中のごみをすべて吸い取るらしいです
パキッ　リピート
うわっ
全部無くしちゃった
かろうじて1個ありました、よかった
ラストチャンスだわ
これでいいですよね、たぶん
これで耳にぶっさすと
もう始まっちゃうってこと？
ちょっと一回入れてみるよ
ほんとに入れるよ
ほぉっ
うわっ、すげぇ
これ、だいじょ
大丈夫かなぁ
吸い込まれている感覚がないですなぁ
吸い込まれてるっていう感覚がないし
ちょっと、風の音がめっちゃ聞こえる
なんか、耳の中で
台風が起きている気分です
はっふぅん
私は思った
これ！
確かに考えは素晴らしいです
バキュームで吸い取って耳の掃除をするって言う
考えは素晴らしいんですけども
なんせ威力が弱いと
これで吸い取っててもなかなか取れてる感覚がない
今回はこれの原理をそのまま利用させていただきます
これの原理を利用して
掃除機の吸引力で吸い込めば
ひょっとしたら耳掃除がもっとこう
快適にできるんじゃないかと思いまして
今回はもっと快適に耳掃除をするために
掃除機をちょっと改造して
耳掃除マシーンを作っていこうと思います
（何でこんなことを思ったんだろう）
（そう思った時には）
（すでに）
（手遅れでした）
ちょっと弱いんですよね
ここは堂々ともう掃除機で吸い取ったって...
うわ 汚！
そこはもうシンプルに
掃除機でやっちゃっていいんじゃないかと思って...
さ
キラ～ン
早い
まだまだまだ
もうさっそく作っていきましょう
まずは、掃除機のヘッドの部分をぶっ壊し...
外します！
このねヘッダーの部分て言うのはね
なかなかね
こう、外そうと思って外せるものじゃないんで
復元できるかできないかって言うね
ちょっと、恐怖もあるのですが
まあ、耳掃除ができるに越したことはないんで
んぁ
オッケー
もうここ取れるんじゃないのこれ
きたきた
何で取れないんだろ
今日取れそうなんだけどな
これなかなか難しいな
一筋縄ではいかんぞ
掃除機ってこんなに難しい作りだっけ
あれ？
ここ取れるんか～い
ぬぉ
はぁ はぁ はぁはぁ
はぁ
あ
これすごいなぁ！（嬉）
あぁ～～～～～～～～～
あっ！
予想以上に強いなこれ
耳の穴に入る大きさに
これを仕上げればいいわけなんで
本当こういう感じね
これで回りをうまいこと囲んで
ちょうど吸い込むところが
本当にストローからしか吸い込まれないようにします
こんな感じでございます
これで掃除機を一回ONにしてみて
完璧です！
まあ、今ご覧いただいたように
しっかりもう吸引はできているので
これでちょっと
今日は耳掃除をしてみようと思います
3,2,1!
ヴぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃ
うわぁ～！
掃除機を個人で分解したり、改造したりしてはいけません。
また、掃除機の吸引力はとても強いです。
吸引型耳掃除機はメーカーが耳を傷つけないよう、
適度な強さに調整してあります。
鼓膜が痛いので
まねすんなよ！